six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number we're gonna go
to our next caller from the six eight
two area code caller from 6-8 - what's
your name where you're calling from hi
this is a Colby in Austin Texas okay and
let's turn Colby up as much as we can I
can't I can barely hear them yeah go
ahead Colby okay sorry about that um so
basically you've mentioned in the past
that you're like you're concerned about
zoos and even aquariums because like the
animal welfare issue and I know you're
aware of like the deforestation and like
dead zones and stuff caused by like
animal agriculture so basically I was
wondering like what's holding you back
from cutting out animal products more
from your life oh I've already reduced
animal products pretty significantly I
mean I could never it would not even
enter my mind to consider veganism but I
could very easily be vegetarian but I
reduce my meat consumption significantly
I basically don't eat red meat maybe
twice a year or something like that at
this point and I'm definitely you know
much more in the direction of the veget
of the Mediterranean diet for sure
alright would you at least like except a
little bit of inconsistency and like
being against azuz for animal welfare
issues but like still supporting like
eating chickens and I mean fish and
stuff like that no not really I mean
I don't you know I'm getting nutrition
from the food that I'm eating I don't
get any nutrition from going to a zoo
right okay cool
all right all right good glad we were
able to uh very quickly get to the
bottom of that one six months I didn't
hit him up to it
six one seven eight the producer vegan
producer Pat did not set that call up